we're potato chili guys how are you how
are you
have a seat pad who Megan I want to say
that I can tell your headline yeah I'm
not saying wow our show Alice Riall -
hello allows Jones at you oh you're
right Alice Joan said she was a
psychopath that was some weird quote
after what a weird contentious after
interview relationship and how John
Jimmy did some of that needs to just
keep it keep it to himself away on it
play your cards closer to your chest
right day you know I mean you don't need
to wear your heart on your sleeve every
time no no one's interested right I mean
we do like to watch people do what we
consider falling apart along our it is
kind of fun to watch like it's a gasp
ekta chol we enjoy I think I can I can
appreciate that and then having just
like a whisper of experiences what am I
need to do just bring this a little
closer can you hear me now yes yes all
right I understand that I think that's a
very human and I also know you must feel
this on some level like having having
some level of visibility it's a
terrifying notion I mean you realize
that like but the people that you're
actually was watching with interest is
their lives kind of dissolve could be
absolutely when I try to be honest so I
think if you're honest if you're honest
about yourself and you and totally I
didn't Ellie tonight I I live by the
same sort of the same ethos and I don't
do anything to make his life fall apart
like if it's happening I'll watch it but
I don't I don't encourage people to hey
boycott him he said that or hey that guy
shouldn't sit you know I mean I don't
contribute to that when bad things
happen it's comfortable to know it will
never happen to you so enjoy it
happening to say oh good I'll never make
it bad it's not the case Wow I mean we
all live that way and then all of a
sudden the house burns down well it
changes what get you in big trouble or
like which wouldn't have last year it
does this year you're like oh I don't
know that was a thing and you want to
talking about it in the wrong way and
people are all over you on Twitter yeah
well I mean I think that what's
happening this year is that is that
issues that were there last year and all
of the other years we've been talking
about them
are now just on the surface and so
people are reacting some in ways that's
that's what a lot of people say that
this is his big reaction has always been
there but there hasn't been a voice to
the reaction and they become violent I
mean people have I mean I think that the
you know the many minority voices has
just been unheard right now we're now
we're just hearing it also part of it is
the reaction and I think we point this
out how you react instantly like our
reaction now is instant so on social
media you see every that's another
interactive reaction and it's not just
like no one just goes huh let me think
about that
yeah and I do this I'm guilty of it too
like I just I mean I said something
about kim jeong-hoon I shouldn't have
said but you know we all make these
little mess
you know anything negative about that no
I liked what he said I don't want to
touch that somebody's got his own reason
right yeah no I think is dennis rodman
follows you on twitter absolutely it's
going to get me does he really
absolutely it's gonna get bad anyone oh
yeah did you shy away from stuff like
that - because you're a public figure
like any any stance you take is wrong -
fifty percent of the people you know I
wish that I could sit here and say I
feel so confident and you know all of my
thoughts and feelings that I just you
know I'm an open book with everything
but I I am aware of that I really am and
I think that it's almost like this is if
this feedback loop is so quick it's
almost like you can read people's minds
or people can read your minds with
social media and so there's no like it's
what you're saying that there's no space
to kind of breathe and sink and sort
yourself out before before you respond
to something sorry I'm sorry just
ridiculous isn't it thank you
but did you know what I mean like
there's like a and that that for me that
level of pressure for me it that
overwhelms me like I get I get I don't I
I need a little I like I need a little
bit of like rehearsal and space and
being an actor too it's different
because like when I say something when
Jim says something like our audience
kind of knows us as people so yeah they
kind of can gauge where our opinions
might be right but like if somebody
knows you from Orange is the new black
they are probably just like whatever
they think I'm
I love her on the show she's going to
think what I think it's a confounding
thing that I've also been experiencing
now doing this show for five years said
there's uh that people conflate me and
my character right so I my character he
might ask me why my character and I know
I mean my characters my character and me
and maybe me and make but yes my very
first by okay yeah you're right I forgot
that my character in me my character and
they give you so the conflation happens
and it's um
I never imagined being in this position
like where people I mean it's like you
know people really think they do you
know you know liked oh well
alright PA James Gandolfini but like the
I like you know the I that like he is
Tony Soprano or something did you hear
I'm talking like oh my god his voice
doesn't you ever watch this pilot for
The Sopranos own you see the first
episode which I think was shot two years
later how different the voices like yeah
he's totally he sounded nothing I
remember that just from watching the
first season of it yeah not even I can't
even really remember exactly the pilot
but I that is so there's already a lot
that people bring to the table expecting
you know having expectations of what I'm
going to say or think or so on that it's
not it's not quite cart once sometimes I
wonder about that like it'd be kind of
fun to just be a person you know name is
right do you get guarded then and not
want to say certain things publicly to
you yeah because the words that can
happen you I always figure like we're
all afraid of being wrong like the worst
that can happen is I say something and
I'm wrong right like half the time I am
give it a Taylor's wrong enough its
headline news well whereas like if we're
wrong it's just like yeah there's
debates on the radio we're wrong they're
wrong every morning hey guys thank you
we talk a lot so you talk a lot you're
wrong more life and get it wrong like
generally in life I really subscribe to
the to the mode of living to the design
for living that you're speaking of you
just sort of like throw stuff out there
and let happen but I do think it just
becomes so overwhelming in my personal
life when you know I say something and
then a lot of people are responding to
it just under day-to-day kind of like
getting coffee and stuff right it's I'm
like
yeah yeah how do you feel that like you
can't go anywhere without people knowing
who you are you can't do anything that
people don't nobody knows people don't
know who I am people know who Piper well
they recognize you right yes people know
that the girl from the girls new black
Piper that's what happens which is
amazing because Piper is an actual
person and they don't recognize me
actual Piper no so you can walk down the
street fine oh yeah yeah that's my
Rhenish for the other thing we live that
way yeah no she's probably based on a
real person she's got a book forget the
whole deal yeah yeah yeah so in that in
that regard because I was thinking about
it like as the show's evolved like it's
not really Piper story anymore it's the
story of everything in the release do
you kind of like that well I mean it's a
mixed bag for sure I mean I I like I I
can't imagine being on a better show in
terms of where we are culturally and
politically I feel like I'm kind of on
the right side of history right now and
they're really happy that we're dealing
with the issues that we're dealing with
and I think I think that the show
founded sweet spot you know like right
what we did the first season and you
know if you saw the first season it just
was basically this Piper Kerman or her
experience of being incarcerated and
that's not that's not the that's not the
story of oranges is black right that's
not the story we're telling that was
just the entry point yeah so you know uh
but yeah I think it's I mean it's nice
it's nice to have so many great people
to work with that's so pretty I mean I
learn a lot at work I've learned the
other activation yeah but Italy like
that we work with they're such skilled
artists yeah and I really learn a lot
from this and you've been nominated for
your have you won or just been on it no
sir I have it when you win you when you
go over here when you so you're
nominated and you go I mean just really
people say that doesn't mean I'm just
happy to be nominated but does it does
it suck when you don't win or you
honestly just don't sure I mean I think
after a period of time I mean it be
honest honest answer to that is that I I
don't really
into the world of like like awards very
much it sort of is like this cult of
like winning and losing that I just
don't believe in I just don't think it
actually exists but when you think
you're going to win do you kind of wait
for it is a really strange dichotomy
because I live it and like I can really
get on that train of because it's really
how I live like I don't really believe
in it I there's like too much gray and
when someone wants to give you an award
you're like oh yes maybe I am too bad
how you'll never make it
they've legitimize this operation yes
you know what now I think they're really
on to something right some are better
and some are worse I don't know if else
and then of course you know the next
season you're not nominated it's back to
this is [ __ ] awesome and you lose to
you Lawson and when you when you go into
it again stood the person who ever beat
you are you think you're like a hawk I
don't have a shot against that person
like like it
I don't even receivin remember I mean
and that be also it's like you know
everything is true it's like all of
these are like both and questions
because well I it was really exciting to
just be sitting at a table with people
that I was like and I wasn't seeing a
table with them but I could see them in
the room and I really respected you're
in the conversation with them right yeah
someone else is now you're like we
aren't having that sounds are talking
about it did you go up and talk to
anybody who you wanted to meet yes I got
very bold one night who did you want me
to talk to you really want to meet
Jessica Lane oh that's her going oh yeah
it's a really good one yeah and I had a
really intense experience that I thought
would never that I've just laughed at or
secretly judged when I've heard people
in my position right now share this I
just had a lot of judgment but I got I
got a little teary what you say I get
weeping I did I don't know why I'm
telling you that right now
were you drinking I know are you so so
what do you say do you see is that you
see you're there and you okay I have to
say hello
yeah because she was hurt you know I
think for many people her film friend
Francis you seen Francis you should
shoot I don't remember no to epic epic
performance are still love ranch in
Colorado one
oh my god she's Louise what an
incredible woman I mean she went from
bishops King Kong to like she's
determined yeah I've got it
so ya know I just expressed to her that
her eye her you know way of storytelling
really influenced me and it made me feel
like I wanted to do this for my life
well did you feel the way about sarsa um
she's probably the you know she she may
and that might be why there it got like
a little like misty eyed yeah because
she may be like the ultimate for me
right there are many things that like
about her on so many different levels I
just I'm such a fan I'm just humbled by
I also I felt that way about Diane
Keaton when almost when I first saw
Diane Keaton he's got a big award a big
like Lifetime Achievement Award no one
invited me no they said Woody Allen and
invoke Pacino spoke Warren Beatty guys
that never talked anywhere I came out
and it was a pretty fun event because
she's in she's she's extraordinary you
know what I mean she brings such she
brings a reality to what she's doing
that it not his unparalleled let's not
leave Faye Dunaway outside either sake
doesn't love Faye Dunaway as US
tradition feud series I haven't watched
oh my god like I was like I was a fan of
Jessica Lange in the sense that like you
know I mean I was a fan before kind of
peripherally because I take the air and
everything American Horse and then when
she popped up on American Horror Story I
was like wow I started to get like into
it yeah and Feud like blew me away much
like the last I told Jim did he have to
play the last two episodes are like the
greatest television I've ever seen
except for oranges the new wife nice Amy
thank you
yeah I'll have to watch it no she's jeez
really exerting and she she has
brilliant work onstage I mean she was
the real she's a real deal my wife likes
Diane Keaton like is obsessed with her
but I've never seen a Woody Allen movie
just why if I prefer much you've seen
two Godfather's mess the beginning men
designing Keaton you know the Godfather
is everything after that she like to all
she likes like 80s like baby boom and
baby boom and on for Diane key well I do
him on the Family Stone yes and my uh
what else has she done all that stuff
but like
Red's you've seen red no no Warren but
it is red right it there's an S on it
nobody I don't know there anyway there's
an S thank you
uh yeah like hope it's not red um but
yeah and then she's brilliant she's a
brilliant actress she wants really she's
a brilliant actress I'm Erin Beatty
wrote that which is probably she wrote
Reds uh-huh what year is that he just
had one he did which didn't do i yet
hidden under someone like 15 years right
did what was always a Howard Hughes day
it might be a little Howard Hughes doubt
like we know a lot about now an
interesting story to choose right like
that story's been told yes ting I
actually haven't seen it and I'm sure
that he has a really specific point of
view he's it's very very bright man
people you also they think to 15 years I
like when you're fixated on doing
something you might just like not
focused other people who just want to
get this project out there and by the
time I feels like right you know I'm
very curious about a your next film that
I was reading about called family oh
great
kids like I've also said things that
I've totally supposed to say I've
totally screwed up talking about that
movie have you yes we have to wait for
the movie is done and then they tell me
what I'm supposed to say about it no but
they're making it oh you don't really
know anything well what have you said
that you aren't supposed to since you've
already said it I mean I can't I don't
want to talk about it
no all I mean is that they're like
creating the movie now and you know if
you said you got vago poured on you um
oh yeah that's real well you know we can
talk about do you know about the Insane
Clown Posse that's all I don't even care
about the movie because I've actually I
have I'm friends with them no yep see
that's why I was going to ask because
when you see this movie they say it's
about
Juggalos in Juggalo culture yes and like
I was worried because it could just end
up being like a Juggalo project you know
to tour the hallways okay what is that
that's I was worried about it as judge
aho is like a fake
Juggalo I'm like Juggalos don't use the
drug a hose oh so it's like a poser
within the Juggalo community anguish ya
know the Juggalo community is very tight
I have a lot of respected family right
yes how can I tell if you're a Juggalo
though you ever seek don't figure - I
love to go up I'm a big yeah I spent
some time in my youth listening
did you really not yeah how they know if
you're a fake Juggalos yoga type you're
a Juggalo you can find it all right you
know it's like they say go down with the
clown till I'm dead in the ground
mother-effing clown loves yeah they
called me a fake I just I was at the
jungle jaii I'm like how about that
Insane Clown Posse guys yeah I thought
that was kind of yeah maybe like no
thank you yeah so there no that's the
real deal I have a lot of I mean did you
become down to clowns here dead in the
ground was i down with the cons lies it
I had you have mother mother [ __ ]
crown love yeah I had some [ __ ]
plantable I experienced them know I like
really I have to say like there were
ding was incredible because for this
movie Buddha there were all these there
were Juggalos that came to support it
because they knew it was like a general
Oh positive yeah I got a little positive
is what you are telling they tried to
clarify the drug laws it's again and
haribol they're not a gang at all we
need more drug alone positive positive
culture like creating a Juggalo positive
culture yes so but they are very uh it's
like very inclusive very loyal very much
like like I have your back now that
you're like you're helping us out and
you know a lot of there's like a space
for a lot of people who self-identify as
freaks which I think most of us do want
some level but they just are vocal about
it I listen to the music yeah you did I
tried to did you did you listen because
there's a song called what is a Juggalo
and it explains what is Juggalo is yeah
did you hear that one not really because
I'm going to be honest in the vein of
living authentically the music frightens
me like it is scary I really do feel
kind of scared by it do you want me to
tell you what a Juggalo is according to
their lyrics oh sure he's not a phony no
he'll come in your house and bust a nut
in your macaroni oh I don't know because
that way it kind of clarifies more that
is that really is that that is the
realest thing you can do yeah but I mean
that's how I know if I really went into
the measure of a man no no can you best
not in the macaroni of course I know the
answer to that [ __ ]
no drop of his nuts in your soup roof
you know a lot of people don't not sure
to Juggalo but that's a
I mean they're real they're it's the
real deal the real deal and I really
appreciate that I mean they're living
they're living it
they are they live it yeah and that's I
mean that's got to be intimidating when
you're making a movie about Juggalos
because if you [ __ ] it up they're going
to beep it oh for sure that I was very
aware of that I felt very aware of that
and I mean it's like you want to do I
just you know like you want to but
generally I feel like people come from a
place of a great you know there's a lot
of integrity at least it starts with
that mm-hmm so I was a guard Sarah and I
want you know it felt I felt like that
we felt very important to you know be
appropriately respectful to the to the
community I need to get a hatchet man
tattoo no sir okay are you better the
gathering I I don't know if I can I mean
I had well just mean your wife as a
person ever
I've never as of yet I haven't been okay
but you might I've got twice it was
actually a you've been to the gathering
like for now yeah twice I was uh you
know it was comedians are scared to do
it so they throw rocks and [ __ ]
sometimes they was right they would
really do they shut base shut throw
feces yeah they don't like you
but the other kind of wildest I know no
outdoor gig is they're good yeah they're
kind of wild no other outdoor gig is
throwing feces though I've got the huge
thing to get old that would suck yeah
yeah I gotta be well legitimately a big
deal to have someone I know and I wonder
like what the logistics of that are did
gathering of the Juggalos or the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] throwing they're probably a lot
of it in the Florida John find out hard
to find if someone sucks you like was to
school there in Sunday to three-day
festival you got a defecate at some
point oh that's why I why they there I
went in and out in one day I went in uh
I go to bathroom yeah I want to go back
to hotel yeah I'm a hotel guy I had an
outdoors person yeah right right not
your natural habit but they were much
nicer than I thought they'd be with the
rapid there's a rapid manner by the way
when they're very nice yeah none of
their wonder I mean I really genuinely
mean that there's like a real deep
empathy and desire to kind of connect so
you've got inmates and Juggalos now on
your side this is huge